he won five NBA championships with the
LA Lakers he won the academy award for
best animated short film he's one of the
greatest NBA players of all time
he's Kobe Bryant and here's my take on
his top ten rules a success volume six
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be driven Shaq's future is certain a
big shift in the balance of power in the
NBA as the league's most dominant player
is headed back east the newest member of
the Miami Fever
remember this I'm gonna bring a
championship to Miami I promise I
thought we split apart were you trying
to get more more championships in me oh
absolutely
you are absolutely and I knew you're
gonna get one I knew you want because of
the energy you know going into Miami and
D way and everything I was there I knew
you were gonna get that one so I knew I
had to get at least two or three I
[Applause]
wanted you to get that I needed that I
wanted that I got wanted people to say
see see this is what they're missing
here this is what they gave up for right
Kobe should have been the one to go now
he's in Miami's we´d like I needed that
one again wanted everybody to hate me I
wanted the fuel off of that and just
come back with so much anger and so much
vengeance so I wanted that so when you
won right after you won I went out to
the track and I ran I did my
conditioning I did my drills I woke up
the next morning I hit my weights at my
house and shots I did everything humanly
possible to get myself ready but I was I
needed outside yeah
good rule number two commit fully you
said I read a quote that you said you
love business as much as basketball
there's no way that's true it's 100%
real there's no way you look I mean
basketball was your life you your
passion everything you you're telling me
you love doing business as much if you
could you know basically snap a finger
and be 25 year-old Kobe or the Kobe
today you wouldn't go back and keep
playing basketball no because I've
already done it see here's the thing
when I was playing and you know
teammates would say Oh Kobe's not out in
the road
what is he doing you see me on the plane
he's reading what is he reading
he's writing what is he writing I'm
practicing I'm writing I'm practicing
I'm understanding how to tell stories
I'm reading Joseph Campbell and how to
create arts compelling arts and plots
I'm reading that stuff so this is going
back 15 years right so I don't just
retire right dear basketball and lucky
in the winning an Oscar you don't say
yes stuff comes from hard work and from
studying for 15 years how to write and
how to organize structure right and you
can't do that without having a serious
love or commitment to the craft rule
number three be a better leader what did
you know and learn at the end of your
career that you wish to you at the
beginning understanding empathy and
compassion because as a young kid when I
came in the league it was like I'm
driving this way and either you're gonna
be on the train or be on the track right
where there was no such thing as
understanding that people have lives
outside of the game which apparently I
did not but like if I understood at an
early age
it helps me as a leader to communicate
better I came to understand that later
and getting to know people on a personal
level whether their fears where their
insecurities where their dreams and
ambitions desires those sorts of things
you come to understand that about a
person then you can help them reach the
best version of themselves
so I wish I'd known that earlier rule
number four perform under pressure
my favorite Kobe moment is in the finals
in Indiana I file out roses 20-foot
jumper no good rebound City Shaq's
a loose ball foul jacket out again I'm
like damn I've got the team down again
and you and you put you put you have my
show so don't worry I got it he just
took over
Kobe fires the jumper and gives LA the
lead Sean
these wire
[Applause]
or you just feel the tension in this
building Richie off the screen the
Lakers take a 3-1 series lead
I knew you was a bad cat but that more
like that you had no fear I was like but
you know I knew how much he meant to you
brothers you don't let yup you don't let
your brother down right wasn't my time
yet this championship was yours
I guess you worked hard to get us to
this point right for your whole career
in Orlando and all the disappointments
and here you are and it's my
responsibility to pick that up also if
you want to learn how to have more
confidence suck of my 254 series they're
free the links aren't in the scription
below if you wake up in the morning and
you're dreading going to work dude do
something else do something else and
those are hard decisions to make but
when you make those decisions it's a
very liberating experience or to go play
someplace else to try to chase a
championship that's not me man that's
not being that's not what my career has
a bit about you start with when you want
your game to be will we make your game
most unstoppable or hard to deal with
rule number five learn from the best was
it a hard decision like I'm going pro or
did you just know cuz a rod obviously
did the same thing yeah you know as a
young kid 17:18 going to be a pro
athlete it was it was a tough decision
I you know ultimately the key factor for
me was wasn't whether or not I was ready
it was the fact that if I wasn't ready I
was determined to figure out how to get
ready and ultimately even if I was ready
I still need to improve anyway mm-hmm
right so the works not going to stop it
was just a matter of do you want to come
to the league and learn from the best
and I'm doing the math in my head I'm
looking at Stockton how many years he's
playing directly how many years he's
playing MJ how many years he's more he's
playing a keen these are players that I
studied growing up and the best way to
learn from them is to have that jump off
of the film jump off of the page and see
it face to face
that's the best way to learn cuz I had
it was like a database I had everything
in my mind would they
do what they didn't like to do where
they did it when they did it now if I
could see that up close that is the
greatest form of Education that I could
possibly receive so that's when I was
like nah I'm gonna I'm gonna go pro rule
number six do what you love and have a
brand you have a shoe but you've chosen
to do something else something that's
that's more bold something that you
really haven't done before can you tell
us why you're doing this why you're
going into a creative endeavor like
Randy studios because I love doing it
it's that simple you know you have to
sit and ask yourself what is truly gonna
get you up in the morning what's gonna
keep you up at night and when you find
what that answer is you stay true to
that
you know I've built a brand for the last
20-some years personal brand which is
great but that is not where our focus is
going to be for the next 50 years
it's what we are doing now and are we
taking a big risk
yeah but I think that if we focus on one
thing and do that one thing
exceptionally well we won't fail at that
one thing so sometimes you got to put
the other stuff to bed and focus on what
you believe is is the core of the
company and that always starts from what
you love to do the most rule number
seven impress others most people Allah
knows I still goes back when I met you
all you know in Orlando yeah I said
we're playing the Pacers in the playoffs
and 94 and I came to a game and you know
Peggy back then was my role model and
you know I looked up to him quite a bit
asked to take a picture with me kind of
brush me off I remember yeah and I came
view as ticket pitching right yeah y'all
fellow were you from November look and
that's when it's the first time I met
you I don't know if you know this but I
was in Atlanta still with the Orlando
Magic I would get a call from from Jerry
West my agent to IEF me and draw me out
of the club Jerry West says I got what
you want but then time I was asked for
150 and no one will get 150 but Jerry
got me 120 so he called me over to the
role and he put the piece of paper on
there and before casaya he stopped
he said let me tell you something I just
acquired this kid from Charlotte you
want him go get about three or four
championships are you talking about say
Kobe brows oh cool
I won't worry about it tonight once for
each other good tonight walk toward it
and that was the first time I knew of
your greatness and then when you came he
was 18 he was doing a lot of I could
remember I came here one time in the
third round to Drew you came out on Sean
rooks and you put a big feeling Kobe
what did you he'll be a great player but
they'll ever do very good rule number
eight demand excellence people that I've
always had issues or problems with are
the people that don't demand excellence
for themselves I won't tolerate that
that then when the career is said and
done they're not gonna be looking at you
I player on his team and saying you
didn't win a championship
no doing me looking here right so it's
my responsibility to make sure
everybody's holding themselves
accountable I'm holding you accountable
if we just play you two back to back and
we have practice the next day your ass
better be there tape ready to go mm-hmm
right cuz I'm there and I'm ready and I
just got finished lifting weights for
two hours right so our whole guys to a
higher standard rule number nine and be
the best you can be I was wondering if
you've had to tone down your
competitiveness in your approach in a
new work environment oh yeah yeah more
than a little bit ya know a well bat
like I said basketball it's different
because it's such a direct competition
what we do now there isn't because the
competitiveness that I bring to work
every day is really helping people in a
sense be competitive with themselves
right if you're if you're animating
something or or you're writing a
screenplay or you're composing a piece
of music is that the best you can do
don't ask me though say do you approve
don't ask me I'm not the musician I'm
not the composer you know right so the
competitiveness is more from an
individual perspective are you is this
the best you can do and if the answer is
yes then off we go
and rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is master your
craft
in trouble quickly drying three from the
corner
[Music]
you can score any quicker than that to
perch at all
no timeout so save yourself
[Music]
[Music]
zero
[Music]
now I've got a such a bonus clip from
Kobe on how to work the hardest that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
the sign for the three-point landing
questions let's go from just watching
the video to taking action here we go
question number one what is the thing
that drives you number two
where'd you need to commit fully and
number three how will you invest in
yourself to be a better leader after the
first championship unhappy that fact in
my mind I'm done I'm gonna do what I
wanted to do I'm here we go to the
parade do that boom I jump on a player
take the ferry back to Orlando I'm
sitting I'll code we never got there for
a championship can they get another one
right will they be known as a Laker
dynasty can he do it again so you know
um I'm mad I'm upset one thing I know I
got I know I got a guy that's gonna be
ready so I made a lot of times I didn't
coming to camera ready
cuz that's just how I got doctored my
thing is I don't need to get ready for
Duncan right I need to get ready so I
don't need to get right I'll get ready
when I get ready so because I had you I
was able to just chill out in the Sun do
it and see that's what you know that's
what pissed me off that was it right
there
that was this I got beat up like that
happy saying I was tired I just know
where I'll blow and swimming me alone we
simply pina coladas we eating burgers my
ass video 10 hours a day when we got my
shot
I got a kid that goes give me 40 where
any words
if you want to stay motivated like Kobe
check out the Kobe motivation video
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there policies I was just
waiting and waiting for my opportunity
to come I wanted to prove that I was
better than they thought I was you know
want to prove to myself